prolongar el gasoducto midcat hasta
francia es lo que propone españa para
hacerle frente a la crisis energética
desde 2005 dichas tuberías llevan el gas
desde argelia para almacenarlo en el
país ibérico mediante la suspensión del
suministro ruso españa ha revivido la
posibilidad de llevar a midcat hasta la
región gala de occitania para lograrlo
se necesitaría construir más de 225
kilómetros de tubería y al menos 300
millones de euros el proyecto además se
tardaría hasta tres años en construirse
aunque españa y alemania defienden la
idea agregando que en un futuro se
podría transportar también hidrógeno
verde francia se opone diciendo que no
es ambientalmente sostenible y que los
dos gasoductos actuales que conectan con
españa no se están usando en su
totalidad conversemos del tema con
gerardo rabinovich
vicepresidente del instituto argentino
de la energía general mosconi bienvenido
a france 24 un placer saludarlo
comencemos por favor por explicar que
smith cut y por qué alemania y españa-
lo defienden
bueno ese como ustedes bien explicó
antes un gasoducto que vincula
españa con el resto de él
españa sería una buena solución para
generar un negocio de
transporte de gas y tratar de resolver
un problema de abastecimiento que
aparece con la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania alemán alemania siempre
publicado de esa guerra y cualquier
punto de abastecimiento le resulta este
benéfico pero digamos francia se opone
porque considera que el proyecto el
proyecto no está maduro
que surge a partir de una situación de
emergencia y eso va en contradicción con
el planeamiento de proyectos energéticos
de largo plazo que requieren profundos
estudios de factibilidad
ambiental social y económica que
pareciera que todavía no están
en un estado de maduración tal que
permita avanzar con el proyecto hoy
podríamos decir que si bien la situación
general
a este tipo de ideas no pasa desde el
punto de vista técnico y de la
ingeniería la etapa de factibilidad y
además de que el proyecto no está lo
suficientemente
maduro francia alega que los dos
gasoductos que ya tiene con españa no
están siendo utilizados en su totalidad
pues actualmente tienen un 55 por ciento
de su capacidad y están funcionando a
este porcentaje en su argumento que
tanto pesan estas ideas de francia
bueno claro esto es un argumento muy
concreto de la inmadurez del proyecto es
decir un proyecto de abastecimiento
desde españa europa implicaría que las
actuales vías de comunicación están
saturadas y entonces se haría necesaria
la construcción de un nuevo gasoducto
españa no tiene gas españa recibe el gas
por la vía marítima en forma de gas
natural licuado y este para poder
justificar la construcción de un
gasoducto
necesita presentar los contratos de
abastecimiento de gas que indiquen que
ese gasoducto se va a llenar durante 20
a 25 años si los actuales hoy están
funcionando a mitad de su capacidad
bueno esto habla de la inmadurez del
nuevo proyecto y los ambientalistas que
se oponen a mitigar alegan que no se
deberían construir más gasoductos pues
esto va en contra de la intención de la
unión europea de lograr la neutralidad
de carbono para 2050 porque sería
promover los combustibles fósiles cuando
están intentando todo lo contrario sin
embargo españa dice que a través de mid
que en un futuro se podría llevar
hidrógeno verde explíquenos por favor
que es el hidrógeno verde y si
técnicamente es posible transportarlo a
través de tuberías que mueven gas de
hidrógeno verde es este hidrógeno que es
el elemento más abundante que era
naturaleza es un gas
sumamente inflamable
que se produce a través de energía
eléctrica renovable eólica
fundamentalmente pero también hidráulica
solar etcétera energía que
no
emite gases de efecto invernadero que no
tiene problemas ambientales y que se
utiliza para la electrólisis del agua
que produzca hidrógeno que sería
transportado como combustible a
distintos centros de consumo
nuevamente el hidrógeno verde es una
tecnología que todavía no está madura
por eso españa dice que en el futuro
podría transportar hidrógeno verde y con
eso contrarrestar los argumentos de los
ambientalistas que son concretos
claramente el mundo está comprometido en
una carrera hacia emisiones meta será de
dióxido de carbono en pocos años para
contrarrestar el problema del cambio
climático y entonces el proyecto de
transportar gas que es una
infraestructura con 25-30 años de
amortización debería cambiar ese este
combustible llega natural por hidrógeno
que es otro gas pero con este otro tipo
de cuidados esté en las tuberías no es
cierto por su carácter inflamable
etcétera ahora hablemos un poco de la
posición de la unión europea que no ha
respaldado del todo a españa y alemania
por ejemplo el midcat no está dentro de
la lista de proyectos de interés común
de la unión europea llamados peak que
hace que la implementación tenga
prioridad y la unión europea tampoco ha
respaldado la financiación porque estas
posturas
bueno nuevamente volvemos a el argumento
este que comentaba antes por la
inmadurez propia del proyecto y por los
argumentos que presenta francia en el
sentido de lo que usted mencionaba de
gasoductos que hoy van entre españa y
francia da una capacidad de transporte
inferior a la capacidad de diseño y por
lo tanto este no desde la unión europea
ese proyecto esa infraestructura esa
inversión todavía no alcanza los
estándares mínimos como para poder
declararlo un proyecto de interés común
no es cierto y este verse beneficiado
con los estándares de financiamiento que
tiene ese tipo de proyectos y teniendo
en cuenta esto que esto nos está
explicando de por qué no hay un respaldo
consensuado el consejo europeo va a
discutir la propuesta de mit cat el
viernes que cree usted que pueda pasar
bueno este probablemente lo más racional
sería que el consejo
indique que se profundiza en los
estudios y
digamos que se presente un informe que
realmente respalde la viabilidad
técnica ambiental y económica de esa
infraestructura para poder asignarle
fondos